hello everyone i'm a few days late to
this because you know i'm at home with
my family
um trying to get in maximum family time
but i wanted to spend today catching up
on a couple of the gaming news things
that i've missed
and i thought that we would continue
watching the dying light
dying to no episodes they basically
released another one it's kind of like a
mini press conference this one's about
half an hour
where they just are slowly giving us a
bunch of information on dying light too
which i'm very
interested in i really love the first
game the second game is doing something
that
i've spoken about in previous videos
basically i'm really
interested in the way that the world
kind of adapts to the choices that you
make i'm hoping this is a bit more
fleshed out than we've seen
in a lot of games who boast this same
claim
but without any more context for me
let's watch it shall we let's do it
27 minutes and 11 seconds let's go
go already
recon be careful
i feel like something bad's gonna happen
maybe
hello and welcome to the second episode
of dying to know
if you missed the first episode you can
still catch it on youtube where you'll
learn more about the game
about the release date and catch the
latest gameplay trailer
today we're going to be talking about
the infected in dying light too
with some of the people who helped
create them but right now i'm sure
you've got like different classes maybe
jonah well jonah is hard at work right
now in la recording some of the voices
for
dying light too so we'll forgive him for
his absence but he has left a message
for you
hey guys uh good news i'm in l.a and
we're finishing up voice recordings
it's so weird to and i say this to
someone who's friends with both troy
baker and nolan north
i don't know this guy but hearing him
speak and
watching the voice come out of a human
when he just so
clearly sounds like a video game
protagonist it's just like doing my
head i'm like no that's how a video game
character sounds i don't
it's so weird this particular quest
we're working on right now showcases a
lot of the disgusting
horrific freaks of nature that you're
gonna fight in the game itself
um the better news is that the episode
today of dying to know
focuses almost entirely on those
monsters and leia is going to
tell you all about them and it's going
to be fantastic the bad news
is i'm not going to be there in the
studio at least this time i'm going to
be in this studio recording lines
for a while but leia's going to take
good care of you
we're going to make sure that you get
everything you need to know and i i
think i
think i got to go back to work um lee
the stage is yours good night
good luck and remember to stay human
thanks jonah well we might not be in
sunny la
probably wasn't necessary to do that
just as exciting to talk about
the monsters we're gonna be looking at
how they're created start talking about
adventuring into the night and then
hopefully we get more combat we're gonna
be seeing what's new on techland gg
and more it seems really clear to me
that they like very much have improved
the
reversal which was already very but
first let's take a moment to thank our
amazing community
combat you i'd like to see more reacts
to our content and your comments help
motivate the entire
team so thank you over 750 000 of you
tuned into the first dying to know live
stream
over 10 million of you have watched the
first gameplay reveal trailer
and over 17 million comments have been
left across our social media channel
that's a lot of comments platforms
amazing
thank you there is literally nobody but
i still feel like this probably doesn't
need to be in this conference
they could make this smaller i think you
could that could be like a social post
or something yes today is mctower the
lead game
designer
hello hi hello hello welcome to the show
um
so we're talking about monsters today
and where the monsters start they start
in the imagination of the game designers
like yourself and the others so
what can you tell us about them so first
of all i think it's important to say
that our sciences used to be sick and
suffering people who just didn't manage
to find
uv light or any other cure in time the
virus causes them a lot of pain and it
makes them suffer
and they are not driven by hatred but by
instinct
their new nature right okay so what is
that it's such a cool setup
oh so cool first you get micros similar
to fever but they faked wind noise in
the background
or even post but if you spend too much
time in darkness
the sickness progresses and your
symptoms become more severe
and eventually you will turn into a
volatile
a quick agile aggressive bloodthirsty
monster
right and if it gets to that point is
there anything you can do is it
reversible
well unfortunately once you have turned
there's no way to revert
and now the uv light becomes your enemy
so if you spend too much time in the sun
you will degrade into a slow-moving and
shambling biter
so with that sun sensitivity then so
it's fair to say you're kind of safe
outside in the daylight apart from the
biters have we seen a shot of them next
to each other
of course you will see less they
understand at different times i think
they might be during the night
but you will still encounter some as the
sun weakens them
they try to find a place to hide usually
inside buildings
but i
okay so i mean you know if i fancy going
in during the day for some reason is
there any chances and no no absolutely
no
no no no his hand was there you do it
during the day it's a certain death
right but you can explore those places
at night okay and
because of that we have greatly yeah it
means the map changes day and night
like more significantly than most games
completely unnoticed
that is as long as you stay quiet and
don't misstep
right okay which is like my kryptonite
because i will absolutely kick a bucket
back no absolutely don't do that never
do that never
tick no never kick the bucket no dying
and not only that but you can encounter
other special infected as well
so can you tell us a little bit about
those absolutely so
they were created by chemicals that made
the infection progress too fast
causing mutations so sometimes when you
stay quiet
sneak behind them and observe them you
will see
that they seem to be uncomfortable in
their new bodies
as if they didn't have time to get used
to them wow okay that's interesting
quite unique and different as well
aren't they well yes everyone is unique
and for example the revenant who's my
personal favorite
uh he has those things called flanky
little legs almost like wings
very dangerous but also smart and
intelligent
and to capture this part of his nature
we have kept his appearance more human
i think smart and intelligent are two of
my least favorite things when
encountering an enemy that's not that
scary she's right
wow well um thank you so much for
joining us today timon thank you for
having me
and now why don't we take a sneak peek
at some of those monsters in action
this is an expensive set they have one
of those cameras
my god that is not cheap i wonder if
it's part of the studio if they've
rented it
seriously riling up the bazaar folks
i'll proceed with caution are we going
you uh wanted to show me something sure
follow me
you won't get far without the
face was not very graphically impressive
but the environments look really nice to
me the lighting especially i think is
what's getting me
not that i can though i don't know why
i'm gonna bring it up
fine with the game not being realistic
as long as there's a consistent door
not even consistent appealing style
[Music]
to look good
sleeping beauties yeah we have to walk
past them
if you crouch and move slowly they
shouldn't notice you they're like
witches in lift
it seems like
get too close and you're done
i wonder what law wise causes them to
sleep
is it a sunlight thing or something
seems odd
[Music]
spores huh chemicals nasty [ __ ]
george house the whole hospital with it
it's a nice indication of variety here
with the patients and stuff stealth
segments relating to zombies and not
just to humans
so i'm worried about this music okay all
right
[Music]
oh no
you wanted to stop the infection at the
cost oh who's
he is large these ones are just vomiting
from their chests
oh my god
we got company
hmm i liked his his face design
this is a nice looking environment
disgusting
but beautiful video games that's how i
feel about the entirety of bloodborne's
yanum
disgusting but so beautiful
just punch a cultist in the face that's
what that looked like
yeah that's great
sorry about this what i'm sorry about
what
about that on behalf of all its [ __ ]
bandits and idiots
earlier
you're about to turn get into the night
fast
hmm that's stressful
it beeping
wouldn't that attract more zombies to
you that seems like a stressful
oh you did some ball running man very
interested in that guy
[Applause]
cool
very good listen my takeaway from all of
that
is i would like to play it which
like even from that segment i was like
yes i would like to play this please
which is what you want
from this kind of segment but i feel
like that doesn't always happen i
usually like watch something like that
and i'm like
i have questions i'm curious this could
be interesting but that
exact segment i'm like sign me up i want
to
hold a controller slash mouse and
keyboard and experience that for myself
thank you and if you want to see
how the creatures we've just seen were
created kashabek the lead character
concept artist
and dominic vashenko the lead 3d
character artist are here to tell us
more
hello welcome to the show hello hello so
my first question for you today is how
did you come up with all of the like
forms and shapes for the monsters so
first we had to create a general idea of
how virus could evolve
visually okay we used elements from
various skin diseases
like hardness tissue working as organic
armor
blisters filled with yellow paths as
weak points
and some burnt skin scars to create
interesting texture
on the skin yeah yeah for example a lot
more research goes into
the real world research might go into
gameplay than i would think most people
and that's because we wanted our
monsters to be like really visible and
recognizable in the darkness yeah for
sure and um
you kind of must have had this idea from
the start then that you wanted the
demolisher to be the bigger and tougher
of the monsters right yeah we knew that
he would throw heavy objects
uh or charge and our goal he was really
monumental and aggressive
just to like to show that strength okay
so the demolish is probably one of the
bigger monsters in the game um have you
got an example of like the smaller
monsters maybe yes of course
for example we have banshee she's
insanely fast and agile because of that
she needs to be of course
the demolisher and she doesn't have like
the heart and tissue that we saw on him
but i wouldn't mess with her yeah we
really wanted her femininity to show so
she's wearing a dress
though it's pretty ragged now and also
she's wearing jewelry that's a sick
dress
and her hands grow larger than the rest
of her body
almost same like in demolishers but here
the disproportion is much bigger wow
yeah and i thought there's a story
behind that with like the jewelry fuses
the body that's so
intense but why are her hands so big
basically they're her weapons so yeah
because she strikes
from above her fingers grow
and also sharper to cut not to hit
because due to her lower strength yeah
she's going for the kill
exactly um so does that mean we can be
expecting banshee to jump from the roof
down on us
yes she's so fast and i'd like that she
might surprise the player like
um thank you so much for joining us
today and uh sharing more about the
process of design thank you
thank you
i could talk to those kind of people for
an hour it's such a cool job a bit of a
treat for you
when it gets dark at night and the
monsters leave their lairs and roam at
the city streets
the residents of the city like to gather
in their safe spots
under the uv lamps for protection and
wait out until the dawn
and when they're doing that they like to
kill time by telling stories themselves
about banshee for example you're
wondering why she's wearing that
beautiful necklace and ball gown
well now you can find out
this is cool didn't expect this all
[Music]
right
do some animation for us okay
[Music]
is it a comic
[Music]
techland have partnered with dynamite to
create a comic series and this
is just a user of what to expect you can
get a thing i actually have really liked
a lot of them
but if you do again ggg.com you can also
get it
frequently quite good in my opinion and
also on techland gg
there is plenty more content you can
find a brand new starter pack
more information about the monsters you
can get a six
piece outfit coming very very soon more
information about the game entirely the
dying to no shows
basically everything so why don't you
check it out for yourself at
techlandgg.com
very cool i'm whispering stop
quite a lot about monsters now but if
there's one thing that intrigues me
it's how do you make something so
inhuman and terrifying come to life
in game luckily we have the one person
who can answer that question here with
us today
it's dying light to's animation director
david lubrica and he's here to tell as
well this stuff is always
super cool to hear or to learn about uh
welcome w
hello welcome hello uh so you work with
the animation team in taking
all that concept and bringing it humans
make video games
breathing modes just the coolest so
where do you even start with that
so the process starts with creating a
prototype uh and then designing
choreography based on this
good shirt then one of those called and
that's where
we have our actors interpret the
movements and
we actually learn from them also that
gives us some extra ideas
so new magic happens when we take
all the things we captured and start
putting into the engine
and into the game's language okay can
you give us an example of that in game
sure like volatile for example so he
sniffs around he searches for his prey
he has those cut like jumps
but many of those movements are actually
characteristics of
the creatures we know from animal
documentaries and he combines them with
some new ones and unique ones and that's
what makes him who he actually is
oh okay okay so i'm going to be like in
game i'm going to be searching him out
and trying to see all these little
details you've made
which it's like so much expertise goes
into every single part
very very distinctive and interesting
behavior he's saying really different
behavior different animations
in game sure to move differently based
on how much muscle they have
he for example uh he's more of an alarm
like this
light you know searching for prey um
he screams to call other infected when
he spots human
but also he sometimes rises on his
tiptoes
to see better to see his surroundings
but that also makes him
look like this very scared you know
panicked child
why is he so scared well it's because
there are some traces of his humanity in
him
he he really wants to scream but the
virus has attacked his
lungs and and vocal cords and that would
just hurt him too much
he's helpless but they all just lose
this fight with their instincts done at
some point
totally actually they rather evoke pity
they you can see that they can notice
the deformations
the virus has done to their bodies they
can touch them
they can experience something like
seizures uh it's an interesting thing to
touch on
that's all this aggression the idea that
we might feel sorry about the press
in them um and you know
something might trigger it and that's
usually an opponent and you can see that
all this energy
is released and transferred on
the opponent on the player for example
us i can't wait to see that in game
um but i want to talk about banshee
because we mentioned her earlier
um we've seen how she looks but like how
is she animated
she's uh she's curious one she uh she
has those really long deformed fingers
uh and she uh uses them to fight
kind of like by products and we have to
imagine how she would feel about them
and we thought i'm not gonna have a good
time looking at these
oh my god i can get really clumsy with
them she falls on them in this very
uncontrolled way
uh it's harder than avoid clipping with
those hands actually
and the dress and then i set for them
she's like inflicted totally she's
really conflicted you can actually see
her sometimes actively hunting you
and then at some point if she gets too
close to you during combat she'll
just suddenly jump back and cower as if
she was trying to resist
the virus but ultimately she would just
interesting thing for them to play with
wow this has been fascinating thank you
so much david thanks for having me
humanizing of the infected is an
interesting
if you've ever watched it if the
infected in the world of dying light you
might be then i've got good news
you can check out okay i haven't dying
but that's cool
and find out whether you'd be i don't
know a violent volatile
a tough demolisher or maybe a human
take the test share it with your friends
because you know you need allies out
here in the darkness
even if you're an infected or maybe
especially
if you're an infected and if you can't
wait until december the 7th to find out
more about the world of dying light why
not check out what's been added to dying
light one
within the last month it's a good game a
million new players have entered the
world of dying light
and we've had the highest number of
active players across all
platforms since launch which is amazing
you
are amazing thank you so much for your
support and your interest it is
seriously a really good game you should
totally check it out more and more fun
content
is a lot of ways to dying light one also
but also like pretty simple
i don't know how well it's aged and if
your head is dying like two comparisons
comparatively gameplay-wise looks
in-game weapon
the wasp so you know why not check out
teclon gg as if you needed more reason
to
um more and more fun content is added to
the game regularly so keep
checking it out with more coming soon
all right well since dying to know is
about the world of dying light
2 there's still something else we need
to hear about
if you pardon the pun because we're
going to be talking about the sound
design of dying light
also love sound design i wondered about
where the roaring the growling
the screaming that covers the streets of
the city at night comes from
then you're in the right place because
we're going to be talking to one of the
lead sound designers
to tell you more
it seems like such a cool drama tomx jet
is here with us today hello
hi nice to meet you you too hello um so
first question do the monsters have
their own language
they technically are not hurt uh
creatures so they didn't develop sounds
to communicate with each other although
there are some exceptions when attacked
he would scream to alert other other
infected and then you can get yourself
into
really big troubles very very very soon
let's talk about the process of actually
creating those sounds though
um so you have to imagine what a
volatile might sound like from
scratch and where do you even start with
that well you know the virus the
deformed
infected in very different ways and you
have to reflect it in their uh
in their voices so for example the
acid spitting monster you know has to
have some with some kind of
acidic characteristics some some watery
hissing uh stuff in it and this is the
banshee a
woman monster and her voice is
high-pitched and
vibrating and really really scary so you
work alongside your twin brother wojtek
and he
also i always love that name a lot of
the sounds that you use to create these
monsters and we actually have a video of
that process
so uh we can have a closer look at what
that entails
honestly sound design stuff's so cool i
had a friend the other day who's
studying sound design right now telling
me about
um making the sound of rain by putting a
microphone next to sizzling bacon on a
pan
it's so funny
[Applause]
[Music]
it's so cool
yeah so now you can see how it works we
always start
with the human throat because all of the
infected
humans wants and then the creative part
is coming and a lot of sound design
magic is happening
also we have to cover a lot of emotions
in in the
infected voices because you have to know
i mean the player has to know
if the infected is uh is in pain or is
super aggressive or is maybe dying you
have to pass this message through the
voice and the message
has to be very very very clear trying to
convey like something
like panic emotions 700 deaths assets
without saying any words and just goggly
sounds trying to communicate
cool challenge sounds um so that's the
monsters but what about the
entire city our city is dying so we had
to find these abandoned places where
there is no
sound of the civilization we visited
abandoned factories we
visited post-military bunkers we went to
the forest at minus 15 degrees because
it sounds completely different than
in the summer and we climb up the
mountains it was a lot of
interesting places we wouldn't visit
without the dying light too and you know
at night with the good headphones
you can definitely enjoy it i cannot
wait to hear it it sounds like you've
got a
fascinating job video games roll man i
love it and i love it
it's so good and you can check out that
i'm pretty fascinated with being that
involved
when dying light 2 releases on december
the 7th
you can become a part of that amazing
universe
remember the ugc contest it's already
started
so just show us your art to be in with a
chance of winning a copy
of the already sold out collectors
edition and join the world
of dying light too just look at all the
amazing things people have already
created
oh somebody read something that's make
two releases later this year
that's cool and you can pre-order it
right now but if you want to dive into
the universe
immediately then why don't you check out
teclan gg for more news
updates they're doing this a bit much
free copy everybody comic you gotta
justify this
whole thing to the marketing team but
when it's like
it's not like there are commercials you
know it feels a bit weird too except for
one thing do it so many times how to
defeat them
so stay tuned for the next episode we'll
be looking at different combat styles
weapon crafting and the iconic dying
light 2 parkour
which was designed in cooperation with
this man definitely do want to see more
by the way i'm a hate gun listen you'll
do better on your own
trust me
thanks for watching episode 2 of dying
to know and remember
the virus isn't the only thing that
makes a monster
so stay human
well thank you for joining me everyone
um i will probably watch all of these so
i guess if you guys
are interested in me watching them with
you then let me know and i will keep
uploading them i can't imagine that i
will not continue to watch them
um because i'm into the game and i like
information
uh i still think that it looks awesome
learning about new enemy types is neat
um a lot of stuff in there that i was
already looking forward to like the
differences between
the environments day versus night and i
don't know i just love hearing devs talk
about the stuff they're making
it's neat so that is it for me today
everyone i will see you guys next time